we're told a boat is traveling at a
speed of 26 kilometers per hour
in a direction that is a 300 degree
rotation from east
at a certain point it encounters a
current at a speed of 15 kilometers per
hour
in a direction that is a 25 degree
rotation from east
answer two questions about the boat's
velocity after it meets the current
all right the first question is what is
the boat's speed
after it meets the current it says round
your answer to the nearest tenth
you can round intermediate values to the
nearest hundredth
and what is the direction of the boat's
velocity after it meets the current and
they say the same well they actually
hear it say
round your answer to the nearest integer
and you can round intermediate values to
the nearest hundredth
so like always pause this video and see
if you can work through this
all right now let's work on this
together so first let's visualize each
of these vectors we have this vector
26 kilometers per hour in a direction
that is a 300 degree rotation from east
and we have this vector 15 kilometers
per hour in a direction that is a 25
degree
rotation from east and so let me
draw some axes here so let's say that
is my y-axis
and then let's say that this over here
is my
x-axis and then that first vector 300
degree rotation from
east east is in the positive x direction
this would be 90 degrees
180 degrees 270 degrees i'm going
counterclockwise because that's the
convention for
a positive angle and then we'd go a
little bit past 270.
we would go right right over there
and the magnitude of this vector is 26
kilometers per hour i'll just write it
26
right over there and then this other
vector which is the current
15 kilometers per hour in a direction
that is a 25 degree rotation from east
so
25 degree rotation might be something
like this
and it's going to be shorter it's 15
kilometers per hour
so it's going to be roughly about that
long
i'm obviously just approximating it and
i'll just write 15 there for its
magnitude
so we can visualize what the boat's
speed and direction it is after it meets
the current it's going to be the sum of
these two
vectors and so if we wanted to sum these
two vectors
we could put the tail of one at the head
of the other
and so let's shift this blue vector down
here so it's at the head
of the red vector so it would be
something like this
and so our resulting our resulting speed
after it meets the current would look
something like this
we've seen this in many other videos so
far
but we don't want to just figure it out
visually we want to actually figure out
its actual speed which would be the
magnitude of this vector
and its actual direction so what is the
angle and we could say it is a positive
angle so what is the rotation
the positive rotation from the positive
x-axis or form
from do east so to do that what i'm
going to do is represent each of our
original vectors
in terms of their components and so
this red vector up here and we've done
this multiple times explaining the
intuition
its x component is going to be its
magnitude
26 times the cosine of this angle
cosine of 300 degrees
and its y component is going to be 26
times the sine
of 300 degrees if that's unfamiliar to
you i encourage you to review it in
other videos where we first introduce
the notion of components it comes
straight out of
our unit circle definition of trig
functions
and similarly this vector right over
here its x component is going to be its
magnitude
times the cosine of 25 degrees
and its y component is going to be 15
times the sine of 25
degrees and now when we have it
expressed this way
if we want to have the resulting vector
let's call the resulting vector
s for maybe the resulting speed
its components are going to be the sum
of each of these so
we can write it over here vector s
is going to be equal to it's going to be
the x component of this red vector of
our original speed vector so
26 cosine of 300
degrees plus the x component of the
current
so 15 times cosine of 25 degrees
and then the y components once again i
add the corresponding y components
26 sine of 300 degrees
plus 15 sine
of 25 degrees and now we could use a
calculator to figure out what these are
to say what these
approximately are so first the x
component we're going to take
the cosine of 300 degrees
times 26 plus
i'll open up parentheses here we're
going to take the cosine of 25 degrees
times 15 close our parentheses
and that is equal to 26.59 if i round to
the nearest hundredth
26.59
and now let's do the y component we have
the sine
of 300 degrees times 26
plus i'll open parentheses the sine
of 25 degrees times 15
closed parenthesis is equal to negative
16.18
to round to the nearest hundredth
negative 16.18
and let's just make sure that this makes
intuitive sense
so 26.59 so we're going to go
forward in this direction 26.59 in the x
direction
and then we go negative 16.18 in the y
direction
so this does seem to match our intuition
when we try to look at this visually so
we now have the
x and y components of the resulting
vector
but that's not what they're asking for
they're asking for the speed which would
be the magnitude of
this vector right over here and so i
could write
the magnitude of that vector which is
going to be its speed
we just use the pythagorean theorem here
it is going to be
the square root of this squared plus
this squared because once again this
forms a right triangle here and we
review this
in other videos it's going to be the
square root of 26.59
squared plus negative 16.18
squared which is approximately equal to
they want us to round to the nearest
tenth
26.59
squared plus
and it doesn't matter that there's a
negative here because i'm squaring it so
i'll just write
16.1
squared is equal to that
and then we want to take the square root
of that we get
31 point if we round to the nearest
tenth 31.1
so it's approximately 31.1
and we'll write the units here
kilometers per
hour is the speed the boat speed after
it meets the current and now the second
question is what is the direction
of the boat's velocity after it meets
the current
well one way to think about it is if we
look at
this angle right over here which would
tell us the direction
the tangent of that angle theta let me
write this down
tangent of that angle theta we know your
tangent is your change in y over your
change in x you can even view it as the
slope
of this vector right over here we know
what our changes in
x or y are those are our x and y
components so it's going to be our
change in y
which is negative 16.18
over 26.59 our change in x
and so to solve for theta we could say
that theta
will be equal to the inverse tangent
and we have to think about this for a
second because this might not get us the
exact theta that we want
because the inverse tangent function is
going to give us something between
positive 90 degrees and negative 90
degrees but the number we want
actually looks like it's going to be
between 270 and 360 degrees
because we're doing a we want to think
about a positive rotation
instead of a negative one but let's just
try to evaluate it the inverse tan
of this of negative 16.18
over 26.59
16.18 negative
divided by 26.5
is equal to this and now i am going to
take the inverse tangent of that
and that gets us negative 31 degrees
which makes sense this looks intuitive
sense that if you were to do a clockwise
rotation which would be a negative angle
from the positive x-axis it looks like
what we drew
but let's just go with the convention of
everything else here let's try to have a
positive angle
so what we can do is add 360 degrees to
that to make a full rotation
around and we essentially have the
equivalent angle so let's add
360 to that to get that right over there
so if we round to the nearest integer
we're looking at approximately
329 degrees
so theta is approximately 329 degrees
so here when i said theta is equal to
this i could write theta is going to be
equal to this
plus 360 degrees
now what's interesting is i was able to
add 360 degrees to get to the exact same
place
if we had a situation where our angle
was actually
this angle right over here not the
situation that we actually dealt with
but if it was in the second quadrant
we would have gotten this theta and we
would have to be able to
realize that hey we're dealing with the
second quadrant that has the same slope
so instead of adding 360 degrees we
would have added 180 degrees and we've
also covered that
in other videos as well